dear Edward definitely on my list of
recommendations but maybe not if you
plan on traveling by plane anytime soon
the content very heavy but surprisingly
there were a lot of laughs behind the
scenes some organic improving character
work and some totally embarrassing
moments Jason cadem's faces in the
editing room as you know this is some
majorly heavy material and because of
that these actors had to do several
reshoots of every scene in like tons of
different ways you don't always know
what the final product should be or how
to pack the punch in the best way
especially because a lot of the time the
end result is something like completely
different so they'd have to reset and
revamp the scene so they had it from
every possible emotional angle we're
gonna have this Buffet of ingredients
and then make the appropriate sandwich
if that makes sense again if you can't
escape the heaviness of this show the
actors don't really want to emphasize it
more than it already is a big theme
wound up being the ability to find humor
in the dark moments we're never pushing
for the tears we're never pushing for
the emotion basically they don't need to
push for it because it's already there
in the core of the story what they
really strive for is laughs and they def
push for that that will help us stay out
of the sentimental Lane I hope a big
behind the scenes Vibe here was keeping
things light especially for Colin
O'Brien this was actually his first lead
role in a project Color Me impressed but
he was super nervous he would also find
himself in his own head a lot using his
real life experiences to bring his
characters to life we're talking super
real like recently losing his
grandfather he confided in Taylor
Schilling about all that and she helped
him through some tough emotions with
breathing exercises which he still uses
to this day Cullen also taught her a lot
about Rocks Crystals and lava Taylor
showed up on set one day and surprised
him with like a malachite rock and
needless to say these two developed like
a major Bond playing their characters
it's not really a really a challenge to
try and connect with someone at least
for me so the connection between the
actors was a huge part of how the script
was brought to life the creator and
producer Jason Tatum's legit wrote the
script by listening to the actors talk
to each other that was how he developed
the voice of the characters and he
wasn't really interested in writing from
the perspective of just getting the
story out he wanted to write from inside
the characters and have the story be
told through them he also found himself
crying a lot on set and in the editing
room watching the scenes and like I
don't blame him he kept trying to hold
them back out of embarrassment but he
just couldn't he found himself
constantly crying over the very words
he'd written so this was one of the
aspects of writing that involved no
tears just laughs what are you doing
yeah drinking champagne by myself out of
a juice class Dede wasn't in the book
she's like a totally new character Jason
developed for the show yeah Jason worked
with Connie Britton on Friday Night
Lights and as soon as she popped in to
his head he couldn't think of anyone
else who he'd rather played Edie one of
the final role that I thought you know
she would sing her teeth into in a very
different way and Jason also loved how
well the actors worked together
particularly when it came to improv most
of the scenes that you see in the show
had tons of spontaneous moments mostly
due to the way it was filmed they always
used three cameras for every scene so
the actors could perform together
without picking it apart character by
character I think audiences really
appreciate it and another genuine
Discovery happened during grief group
before shooting those moments director
Allison Liddy Brown knew to take the
lead and set the scene for everyone she
said hi welcome to your first grape
group scene I'm your director Allison
this is a space where we honor those who
have passed it was actually pretty
method in the way they approached it
doing those scenes was like being in an
authentic brief group it was special and
sacred for the cast as they really came
forward with their loved ones on their
hearts for me it became a time to
reminisce on on my grandmother who had
passed several years ago so did anyone
else know this was a book originally
surprisingly a lot of the actors didn't
read the book before diving into the
show as they didn't want to distract
from the world that Jason cadems built
the book has a clear ending but Jason
took that narrative and changed it to
fit the way he wanted to tell the story
he wanted it to be more about the
characters that he created instead of
following the linear path of the book he
also opened up the narrative in a way
that creates a path for future Seasons
so do you think this was the right way
to tell the story or would you have
preferred he stick as close as possible
to the book like honestly dear Edward
pulls Us in for a totally fresh
narrative from the world of the book
that we know with the actors doing their
best to show up authentically using
their real life experiences and
tragedies the spontaneity they captured
in every Ensemble scene and Jason
cadem's crying over his own words we're
definitely in for a ride who is your
favorite character in the show